bonjour à tous bienvenue de nouveau à
bruxelles ici au parlement européen pour
cette émission spéciale scrutin nous
allons revenir longuement sur le
résultat des élections européennes de ce
dimanche est tout de suite directement
la question de la semaine posée par
simon barbarie les europhobes ont-ils
rafler la mise
une claque une débâcle un séisme le ton
était tragique dimanche soir chez les
commentateurs et oui c'était prévu les
grands gagnants de ces élections
européennes sont les partis populistes
en france avec 25% des suffrages le
front national est à la fête 24 sièges
au parlement européen
c'est bien mais pour marine le pen le
parlement français c'est quand même
mieux à la démocratie français seul le
peuple est souverain alors il faut
revenir au peuple dissoudre l'assemblée
imposer la proportionnelle et faire de
nouvelles élections pour qu'enfin cette
assemblée soit nationale est
représentative comme en france au
royaume uni c'est le parti europhobe
ukip de nigel farage qui arrive en tête
et là encore europhobe n'est pas un
euphémisme
sinon en grèce l'aube dorée le parti
néo-nazi récolte 9% des suffrages autre
parti fascisant le jobbik arrive en
deuxième position en gris mais si
rappelez-vous le parti qui qualifie les
roms de parasites et surprise même en
allemagne les néonazis du npd arrive à
obtenir un siège quand le parti anti
euro la sève des créoles ya un an à
peine récolte lui près de 7% des
suffrages une info ni toutefois comment
rassembler au parlement des europhobes
et eurosceptiques et des néo-nazis qu et
comme il faut 25 députés d'au moins sept
pays différents pour former un groupe
marine le pen à elle une petite idée sur
la question vous savez on peut très bien
avoir des intérêts communs
évidemment maîtriser l'immigration je
pense que c'est un intérêt commun à
l'ensemble des nations européennes alors
l'extrême droite parviendra-t-elle à
peser dans le futur parlement européen
et pour répondre à cette question j'ai
plusieurs invités avec moi en plateau
nathalie brac bonjour bonjour vous êtes
politologue à l'université libre de
bruxelles et à oxford rené monory
bonjour bonjour vous êtes correspondant
du journal les échos à bruxelles et
lorenzo consoli bonjour vous êtes
journaliste italien correspondant le
team news alors nathalie break je me
tourne tout de suite vers vous on
s'attendait à un raz-de-marée populiste
est ce que c'est le cas oui je pense que
c'est c'est clairement le cas c'était
attendu donc ça vient pas vraiment comme
une surprise mais en effet il ya dans
certains états un raz-de-marée
eurosceptiques ou souverainistes mais
enfin la situation est quand même très
diverses en fonction des états on peut
pas vraiment comparer l'ensemble des
états membres donc entre le nord et le
sud par exemple les situations sont très
sont très contrastées rené honorer la 25
% pour le front national en france on
parle le premier parti de france ça
affaiblit clairement la position
française au sein des institutions
européennes
clément ont déjà tous les français que
vous croisez ici à bruxelles rase les
murs ils ont un peu en devises à vie
leurs collègues mais au delà
affectivement c'est à ce pape est
anecdotique ici même au parlement
européen a effectivement l'influencent
française va nécessairement des croix
dans les prochains dans les cinq
prochaines années
les 24 élus fn sur les 75 députés
français c'est autant d'élus qui ne
joueront pas le jeu parlementaire ici
qui fait de compromis ils ont déjà
annoncé qu'ils allaient la délégation
espagnole en fait est quasiment donc
voilà donc vous avez déjà un tiers de
votre délégation qui a dit qu'elle ne
jouerait pas le jeu et donc il n'aura
aucune influence sur ce qui va être fait
ici est assez ensuite des délégations
qui sont considérablement affaibli l'ump
avait passé de faim l'ump au sein du ppe
est passé de 30 à 20 élus le ps aura que
très élus au sein des socialistes et un
panda est historiquement bas ils ne
poseront très présent très peu dans le
jeu de compromis de négociations qui
auront lieu dans les prochaines années
lorenzo consoli vous depuis l'italie
quelle est votre lecture un petit peu de
ce problème populiste vous avez réussi à
contenir finalement la problématique
ligue du nord si je puis dire comment
est ce que vous voyez vos voisins
européens sur cette problématique là il
ya un ami français qui travaillent
conseil me disait l'autre jour
l'italie a sauvé l'europe
oui c'était un français que le disait
mais c'est vrai que le lierre le premier
ministre italien ici à bruxelles a dit
lors du conseil en r oui les 11 millions
de voix qu'on a eue nous le parti
démocratique démocratique italien
en effet de les populismes mon sens sont
la réponse au populisme en italie ont
fait là les 40% que monsieur rainsy a eu
à doubler le voit des greens et l'eau
qui était considéré un peu le ep gré le
moment cinq étoiles voilà la voie
dentier anti anti euro plus qu'un
européen parce qu'ils sont pas vraiment
inquiet robben mais c'est vrai que c'est
une set c'est un cadre complètement
différent par rapport à la france à
l'angleterre je crois que là la question
importante maintenant on l'a vu hier
soir c'est la réponse que les
institutions européennes vont donner et
c'est qu'on a vu hier soir
ce n'est pas très beau parce qu'en fait
le constat on va en parler on va en
parler de la question de la future
commission nathalie brac est ce que ce
groupe populiste si toutefois il arrive
à se constituer ce n'est pas encore fait
peut bloquer les institutions
européennes il faut voir ce qu'on entend
par groupe populiste et sont extrêmement
hétérogène comme on l'a vu ces dernières
semaines ils font des exclusives donc le
you keep de nadjaf ne veut pas
collaborer avec le front national le
front national ne veut pas collaborer
avec aube dorée ou avec jobbik en
hongrie donc ils sont chacun des
exclusives en dix ans les autres sont
non fréquentable parce que non
démocratiques ou trop extrêmes donc ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils arrivent à se
fédérer en un seul groupe dont qui
risque d'avoir s'ils y arrivent
plusieurs groupes eurosceptiques à
droite et si marine le pen arrive en
effet à former son groupe comme elle l'a
dit son objectif n'est pas vraiment de
contribuer au processus législatif
donc on dirait que dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale française voilà elles lisent
des réveils ou nationales mais pas au
niveau européen ça leur donnera
toutefois accès par exemple des
ressources financières à des ressources
en termes de personnel au sein du
parlement européen une voix à la
conférence des présidents mais je pense
pas qu'il sera en mesure de bloquer
cette espèce de fantasme du blocage des
populistes au niveau européen quand on
voit nigel farrage qui dit il faut
sortir il faut abandonner le drapeau il
faut que l'europe sorte de l'union c'est
un fantasme complet c'est pas possible
non mais ça ne passera pas d'abord par
le parlement européen ça passera plutôt
sur une influence sur les partis
nationaux et sur des revendications qui
se passe au niveau national comme le
youki paris va faire défié par exemple
le parti conservateur en durcissant ton
sur les questions européennes où ça peut
se passer dans d'autres états où le
principal parti à droite ou à gauche va
durcir le ton sur la question c'est le
cas à renault quand on voit l'angleterre
avec david cameron et sa droite donc le
you keep
ou alors en france l'ump face au front
national on risque de voir au sein de
l'union européenne ue globalement une
droitisation sur des questions sociales
au musée rath clairement à risque ou là
de la droite européenne si vous écoutez
ce qu'a dit françois hollande lundi soir
lors de son intervention télévisée avait
quand même un discours que david cameron
aurait pu prononcer deux ans auparavant
quand vous dites est en train de dire
françois hollande s'est droitisée bas
d'une certaine manière oui quelles
thématiques il a abordé lundi il faut
que l'europe se recentre moins d'europe
david clément dis ça depuis deux ans lit
enfin il a reparlé aussi des questions
de frontières d'immigration dont il
n'est pas sur une réforme de schengen la
rejette schengen comme on peut
l'entendre à droite en france à l'ump
mais malgré tout sonde était là quand
même venu voilà plutôt de la droite et
qui maintenant sont ras de la renaudière
marchais dans les transitions parce que
justement sur cette question là je
voudrais qu'on réécoute le président de
la république est derrière une petite
réaction également dans gala merkel la
chancelière allemande on écoute
l'europe elle est devenue illisible j'en
suis conscient lointaine et pour tout
dire incompréhensible même pour les
états ça ne peut plus durer le rappel
doit être simple clair pour être
efficace là où elle est attendue et se
retirer là où elle n'est pas nécessaire
je suis européen mon devoir c'est de
réformer la france est de réorienter
l'europe l'europe elle a réussi
notamment depuis deux ans à surmonter la
crise de la zone euro elle était proche
de déplacement mais à quel prix celui
d'une austérité qui a fini par
décourager les peuples
nous sommes très heureux que notre union
soit devenu est la plus importante force
politique en laissant loin derrière les
sociaux-démocrates et nous pouvons aussi
nous réjouir que les parti populaire
européen représentent le groupe le plus
important
concernant les avancées des partis
populistes et d'extrême droite elles
sont notables est regrettable il s'agit
avant tout de regagner ses électeurs et
cela vaut aussi pour la france
lorenzo quand vous voyez françois
hollande qui dit que l'europe est
lointaine illisible même pour les états
c'est un peu facile pour vous deux
tant d'avoir ce type de justification ou
c'est vrai il n'a pas tort le problème
est qu'il ya deux types de critiques
qu'on peut faire l'europe la critique
des populisme de droite conviennent
attendre de falla jo dehors de marine le
pen une critique je crois que la
critique du ronde est quand même
différente parce que il dit carrément
que le problème qu'il y a eu
dernièrement ça a été dans le déni en
aide de crise c'était là lance-t-il
c'est l'hostilité dernier les citoyens
du treuil euro et après c'est un peu
gonflé entre guillemets que les chefs
d'état 10 c'est de la faute de
l'austérité sachant que c'est eux qui
l'ont décidé aussi au sein du conseil
oui hélas il faut dire que par exemple
la france a manqué complètement déjà
depuis l'allée bordée sarkozy à son
devoir de 2,2 contre balancer un peu là
l'influencent del alemagna l'allemagne
est devenue complètement et j'ai mon
europe et le prix c'est ça en boîte très
bien aussi être aux élections
européennes on l'a vu la lémance et
concile à lehman n'était pas en europe
le résultat électoral les mots qui a
primé
tout le reste de dpi de ramper le
symbole de leur solide et donc le
symbole vraiment de l'heure de l'europe
qui a été refusé par la cgt par des
citoyens nathalie brac comment est ce
que vous vous lisez cette espèce de
fracture entre e.on en gala merkel toute
puissante qui a qui est sortie des urnes
renforcé quand même avec 36% des voix et
jean françois hollande complètement
décati avec 13% et un front national à
25% il ya une fracture entre je vais
faire vraiment quelque chose à un
raccourci un peu simpliste entre les
pays latins et
enfin c'est une fracture nord-sud au
sein de l'europe je pense qu'on voit en
effet une fracture nord-sud des effets
de la crise économique et
en particulier par exemple on voit dans
l'europe du sud peut soit un vote plutôt
à gauche par exemple le mouvement qui
s'y pressent en grèce qui avait beaucoup
mieux que hobo matteo renzi d'ailleurs
en italie mais quand même dans le cas
français fin ce qui moi m'a frappé dans
les déclarations de françois hollande
c'est d'une part de faire passer ça
comme c'était un vote de désamour de
l'europe entièrement alors qu'il me
semble quand même qu'il ya des facteurs
nationaux très important un contexte
d'impopularité du gouvernement qui est
qui n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
l'europe et il ya de façon générale ce
vote eurosceptique et un vote anti
establishment à peu près dans tous les
états et puis dans la plupart des états
aussi et la france en particulier à ce
double discours de toujours rejeter la
faute sur bruxelles pendant cinq ans et
puis après de s'étonner que les
électeurs n'aiment pas bruxelles ne
comprennent pas bruxelles et les
trouvera les enjeux illisibles ou il
mais bon renault n'aurait en gros le
chef de l'état c'est un peu facile la
faute à bruxelles l'europe illisible
même les états n'y comprennent rien oui
c'est pas le premier à la fête et la
photo le temps de la frontière nord non
ce qui est surprenant c'est que ce soit
françois hollande week-end et il
n'allait pas habituelles voilà plutôt
qui veut qu'on présentait comme son fils
spirituel de jacques delors qui est lui
aussi maintenant finalement se mettre à
ce discours ces voix-là
électoralement c'est payant ce type de
discours fins est pas là ça il me serait
même en italie matteo renzi a été assez
parfois durs envers les institutions
européennes et d'une manière générale
c'est une petite musique qu'on entend de
plus en plus en europe en angleterre on
le savait mais également en allemagne
aux pays bas où j'entendais beaucoup de
voix qui commence à dire bruxelles a
trop de compétences il faut rapatrier
dans les capitales nationales tous
attendent effectivement à ce que les
institutions européennes dans les années
à venir soit un petit peu sous le feu
des critiques et doivent se défendre
pour question de réorienter l'europe
parce qu'en france ça fait deux ans que
il nous dit françois hollande depuis son
élection qu'il va réorienter l'europe
nathalie braquer ce qu'il est possible
de réorienter l'europe sans changer les
traités sans repasser dans le cadre de
référendum nationaux est ce que c'est
possible mais c'est possible si en effet
ça dépendra par exemple du président de
la commission quelles seront les
orientations brownies et c'est pour ça
qu'on peut mettre
l'accent sur certaines thématiques qui
sont au coeur des préoccupations des
citoyens comme l'emploi la croissance et
c'est donc ça c'est possible de
réorienter les dynamiques et les
orientations économiques et sociales de
l'europe de façon des rats sans passer
par des raisons passé par là aussi c'est
aussi l'impression d'une autorisation
des traités il ya un problème lorsqu'on
a une interprétation de la part de la
pensée unique néolibérale est allé monde
aussi qu'ils
essayent de qui essaient d'utiliser les
traiter ce pour cette europe des
créditeurs et qui ne voient pas dans les
traités même dans le pacte de stabilité
tous les tous les points qui pouvaient
donner plus de 1 pouce de marge de
manoeuvre aux états pour justement faire
des investissements publics est sortie
de crise
c'est une question d'interprétation oui
mais après il ya bien cette barrière des
3% de déficit que personne ne veut
bouger angela merkel lors du conseil
européen disaient les traiter les
traiter les traités on touche pas aux
traités dans les traités c'est ce qui
marche pour la france c'est la question
du 3 % parce que la france n'arrive
qu'en mai en italie on a en a on est
allé à
2,5 si c'est que c'est là et on est bien
on continuera bruxelles à taper celui
d'ali en disant non vous devez arriver à
zéro donc finalement ce n'est même pas
le 3 bon sens si c'était le toit vos
sens
assez bien de toute façon c'est quand
même pour moi c'est une convention pour
fr3 5 4 mais dont le traité il ya
travaux sont d'accord mais le problème
est que l'interprétation que l'allemagne
et bruxelles ont donné de paddy
stabilité une interprétation rigoriste
et en solitaire qui qui mène droit
contre le mur parce que on a tendance à
donc dans des années de crise en lieu de
fait l'investissement public on a
continué à couper le budget on a
continué à couper les déficits en disant
qu'elle rencontre le déficit on aurait
diminué la la dette les déficits ont été
coupées la dta augmenté donc c'est un
problème d'interprétation des deux
pattes et stabilité et des traités et de
qui est à la tête de la commission et
qui est le commissaire aux affaires
économiques et monétaires
comme un libéral aux as et pensait
justement là la question s'ouvre sur le
futur président de la commission on nous
a vendus pendant ces élections vous avez
le choix c'est vous qui allez décider
quel sera votre futur président de la
commission et les tractations ont
commencé dès dimanche soir dans une
cacophonie un peu général on écoute ce
reportage et on en discute en plus
23 heures passées de quelques minutes le
porte parole du parlement annonce les
premiers résultats
nous voilà à nouveau merci beaucoup de
votre patience verdict des urnes le
parti populaire européen arrive en tête
malgré un net recul par rapport aux
précédentes élections en seconde
position les socialistes échoue à
devenir la première force politique de
ce nouveau parlement fort de ce résultat
joseph daul président du ppe revendique
clairement la victoire le ppe arrivera
en tête et proposa donc son candidat qui
est jean claude juncker comme président
de la commission juncker futur président
de la commission européenne chargé de
former une majorité au parlement
une éventualité que réfute martin schulz
candidat des socialistes en europe sur
la base de notre programme nous devons
construire une majorité
si nous verrons qui avec son programme
peut construire cette majorité au
parlement européen mais face à la
difficulté de former une majorité
absolue de 3 176 sièges guy verhofstadt
candidat libéral se pose en alternative
aux deux partis majoritaires a été je
pense qu'il est possible de construire
une majorité sur la base de notre
programme et de ma candidature
en somme chaque candidats revendiquent
la capacité de construire une coalition
incroyable et peu compréhensibles alors
jean claude juncker remet les pendules à
l'heure il faut respecter les lecteurs
non pas parce qu'il est l acteur mais
parce que les citoyens les citoyens
européens aujourd'hui viennent de
désigner d'une façon ultra clair le
premier parti de l'europe je compte bien
que les autres parties cessent
de donner l'impression que les résultats
des élections concours peu mais que leur
volonté politique plus importante que
l'expression claire du suffrage
universel continental dans cette
cacophonie les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement auront aussi leur mot à
dire et il risque d'être peu enclin à se
laisser dicter leur conduite par les
parlementaires alors peut-être une
solution de nombreux votants croiser
aujourd'hui m'ont demandé pour quelle
raison ne peut-on pas voter directement
pour le président de la commission une
bonne manière aussi peut-être de lutter
contre l'abstention endémique dont
souffrent les européennes
renault qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours est ce que l'on voit
cette cacophonie de dimanche soir entre
temps le conseil sur les chefs d'état se
sont réunis en dîner informel lors d'un
conseil européen
est ce que il ya quelqu'un qui va sortir
du chapeau qu'est ce qui va se passer
bah là maintenant ça va être le
traditionnel tour de table et rata des
tractations qui peut durer des jours des
semaines généralement auparavant ça
s'est terminé par une ce qu'on appelait
une nuit des longs couteaux ou les
genres les chefs d'état resté pendant
des heures pour s'accorder finalement
sur un nom sauf que là effectivement le
processus a changé on est censé tenir
compte quand même de ce qui a été dit et
ce qui était voté dimanche donc là on
rendra dans une phase un peu inédite ont
un petit peu découvrir aussi on va
tâtonner pour voir comment ça se passe
là clairement de ce qui ressort un petit
peu de ce qu'on dit les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement lors de leur réunion
mardi c'est que c'est quand même assez
équivoque par rapport à ceux par rapport
à ce qu'on appelle le speedcell candidat
donc le le candidat de chacune de chacun
de dd chacune des listes des partis
européens
tous ont eu des déclarations plus ou
moins équivoque par rapport à ce qui ce
qu'ils voulaient vraiment ou non
respecter le choix des électeurs après
ce qu'ils sont dans la capacité de
d'aller à l'encontre de ce que les
électeurs
on donnait comme ça sera assez bizarre
quand même pendant toute la campagne
plusieurs galas merkel a jamais été très
clair là-dessus mais par contre par
exemple françois hollande dans une
tribune au monde ya quelques semaines
avait dit clairement les électeurs pour
la première fois vont voter pour le prix
pourrait lire de façon indirecte le
président de la commission européenne ça
serait un petit peu bizarre quand même
trois semaines après dire ah bah non
finalement on vous sort quelqu'un
d'autre d'une relation
on peut on critique souvent le manque de
démocratie européenne leur a quand même
fait une tentative nathalie brax et
inédit cette tentative de
démocratisation et anais svoboda donc et
le président du groupe socialiste
démocrate disais pourquoi pas à terme
une élection au suffrage universel c'est
autant dable ça pour les chefs d'état ça
se demanderait par contre une révision
des traités donc c'est clairement une
tentative à l'heure actuelle pour
personnaliser le scrutin tourne à briser
un là pour mettre des têtes sur les
parties et sera moyennement marché mais
bon on a quand même eu moins
d'abstention qu'en 2009 voilà ça s'est
stabilisé donc c'est la première fois
depuis 7 81 79 que ça s'est stabilisé
après il faudra voir en effet est ce que
le parlement parvient à maintenir une
position ferme vis-à-vis du conseil donc
on a vu hier qu'ils ont émis donc une
un mandat d une déclaration de président
le parlement s'est déclarée donc à
nouveau en faveur du fait que mon coeur
soit le premier à essayer d'obtenir
cette majorité donc on voit déjà les
discours un petit peu changé puisque on
reconnaît officiellement que c'est donc
une coeur qui a le droit de commencer en
premier et puis on voit quand même
martin schulz qui vont en tout la
campagne a dit ce sera la première
famille politique et maintenant ce sera
celui qui parvient à obtenir une
majorité donc il faudra avoir un peu au
niveau du parlement s'ils parviennent à
maintenir une position ferme et puis ce
qui se passera au niveau du quai pour
nous france a typiquement parce qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans une démocratie
parlementaire donc il ya une forme
d'incompréhension dans cette capacité à
produire ou délocalisés coalition c'est
pas du tout l'autre ça exactement
identique donc du coup c'est un petit
peu il faut faire un petit peu de
pédagogie autour de ça lorenzo qu'est ce
qu'elle est l'enjeu en fait si jamais
bas fin juin le juncker n'a pas réussi à
construire une majorité est ce que du
coup on va se tourner vers martin schulz
qui a plus de réserves de voir sur sa
gauche et est ce que le risque si on car
fait une espèce de coalition avec le ps
les libéraux les verts etc c'est qu'on
se retrouve pas fait ça ce que le front
national typiquement en france à bord
c'est à dire une coalition droite gauche
centristes qui en fait ça tout le monde
gouvernent l'europe et personne ne sait
où on va la coalition et se paie
peut-être si libéraux
c'est une obligation là où on est parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres d'autres
majorités possible soit 176 sièges pour
avoir une majorité la majorité de centre
droite que dans les dernières parlement
était toujours à plus ou moins possible
là c'est carrément impossible parce
qu'il ya un quart des voix qui sont
eurosceptiques mais mieux qu'elle a dit
moi je n'accepterai pas les voies delà
de la droite des populistes donc il n'y
a qu'une majorité possible c'est la
majorité pc peu avait pété libéraux et
la chose importante c'est de voir quel
est le programme dont quelles sont les
conditions où les socialistes vous
contribuez à
majorité avec les populaire et dans le
cas où une ue qui n'arrivent pas à
former cette majorité le parlement l'a
déjà dit alors ça
l'initiative et à tous les noms oui
c'est un certain nombre du papier
effectivement il ya du parti populaire
effectivement on le sait david cameron
n'a jamais fait
a toujours dit qu'effectivement il
resterait opposé à juncker on sait que
que les hongrois également d'autres pays
vont sans doute se joindre ce mouvement
dit juncker donc qu'est ce qui va
ressortir effectivement est ce que les
est ce que l'allemagne la france va oser
aller contre l'angleterre la mettre en
minorité ça va être un petit peu aussi
l'enjeu des prochaines semaines après il
a été aussi question mardi donc lors de
ce conseil repaire d'un mandat pour la
future commission qui serait plus axé
vers l'emploi vers la croissance vers la
transition énergétique
nathalie bras qu est ce qu on a les
moyens de cette politique sachant que
les budgets ont déjà été fléchés et voté
lors de la précédente législature
oui donc effectivement ils sont
contraints par par le cadre budgétaire
qui a été déjà et la migros là des
paroles en l'air mais ils peuvent quand
même mes verres d accent particulier sur
la politique qui sera menée comment on
l'interprète voilà les politiques qui
doivent être menées quelles sont les
priorités pour les cinq prochaines
années au sein de la commission est
effectivement à commencera seront
attribués à part ensuite les
portefeuilles clés de la commission et
notamment comme on disait les lorsqu'il
connaît les lorenzo tout à l'heure sur
le portefeuille des affaires ont dû
parler légèrement tendus par dont un
dirigeant être contre la croissance donc
en tant que l'europe valls doit se
retourner vers la croissance très bien
mais encore et il vous faut trouver
aussi un point d équilibre sur ce qu'on
met dans la croissance entre david
cameron et françois hollande je pense
pas qu'on combat qu'on ait la même idée
en tête quand on parle de la croissance
donc cette idée qu'ils formaient le rox
au choix de la croissance c'est un
discours qu'on entend ici à bruxelles
depuis au moins deux ans mais cas pas
pour l'instant débouché sur un grand
terrien est un réorientation d'être même
je rencontre les anglais à merkel et
françois hollande ya par exemple eu la
même interprétation sur la façon de
faire donc pour l'instant
reste quand même très floue cette idée
de sensations d'émotions continue à
parler de croissance de
travail de d'investissement et ce sont
des monts alors que quand on fait les
politiques d'austérité ce sont des actes
qui pèse énormément
mais le problème je reviens là le
problème aujourd'hui c'est un problème
d'un conflit institutionnel possible que
je vois arriver au claj entre les
parlements il a blocage conflit a confié
vrai parce que le parlement on va
continuer dire que ukr c'est le candidat
et donc vous devez vous vous prononcez
par rapport à ça 11-0 chefs d'état de
gouvernement et non pas créer un
processus parallèle comme ça qu'on fait
avec vannes un peu qui va négocier avec
lego politique alors qu'elle vaut
politiques ont déjà candidats mais la
difficulté c'est de se mettre d'accord
sur un programme commun donc est ce que
on peut dire qu'il ya un programme
commun possible entre juncker les
sociale familiale et sociale c'est
possible mais le même mais le problème
est que là on voit bien accomplir si
vous aimez parce que les chefs d'état et
gouvernement ne veulent pas renoncer à
la prérogative qui jouait jusqu'à
présent d'être les faiseurs de roi ils
ne veulent pas renoncer à sa est le
parlement est déterminé à rejeter un
candidat qui ne soit pas soit uk reçoit
un autre des candidats qui sont sortis
de cette sélection nathalie braquer les
le l'enjeu là en l'occurrence sur ce
blocage institutionnel c'est plus de
démocratie en europe finalement plus
dorée représentativité les chefs d'état
quel est le quel est leur intérêt en
fait à bloquer comme ça vient il ya deux
ans je ya en effet la question de la
crédibilité et la démocratie dans une
aubaine de tenir ses promesses
électorales en quelque sorte et il ya un
enjeu purement institutionnel de comment
va se faire la l'equilibre des pouvoirs
est donc ce qu'on doit se jouer au
niveau des chefs d'état et gouvernement
il y en a certains qui dirige compte
juncker en tant que personnes qui ont
passé idéaux qui n'aime pas sa
personnalité mais d'autres en termes si
l'on compte le processus ils ne veulent
pas que le parlement soit prenne la
fonction de faiseur de roi et donc qui
désigne le candidat président de la
président de la commission donc c'est
sûr le processus même et c'est de savoir
qui va avoir le dessus entre les deux
institutions et renault dernière
question une fois de plus si je puis
dire je vais un petit peu provoquer les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ça soit
sur sur le peuple on construit l'europe
contre les peuples ou pas dans ce
processus là est encore un peu trop tôt
pour le dire on verra effectivement à ce
que l'issue de la bataille en un mois
dans entre les entre les deux
institutions quoi mais c'est justement
effectivement c'est tout l'enjeu de ces
élections on voit voir effectivement
s'il ya un embryon de démocratie
européenne qui peut émerger à la faveur
de cette crise parce que c'est de la
merde crise effectivement on manque
souvent le manque de démocratie
européenne souvent un petit peu parce
qu'on comprend pas comment ça marche
parce que surtout vu de france à la
façon dont dans les compromis ce fond on
a l'impression que c'est c'est un petit
peu voilà une sorte d'ersatz de
démocratie mais malgré tout il ya quand
même des vraies bases ici et donc la
voie là et ont essayé de passer par une
étape supplémentaire souvent les gens
sont impatients on dit en disant que
l'europe n'est pas démocratique mais
faut rappeler que dans tous les pays
d'europe occidentale la démocratie s'est
pas fait en vain en hitler et ben
écoutez merci beaucoup pour ce
débriefing complet de ce scrutin nous on
se retrouve alors pas tout de suite mais
le mois prochain en juillet justement
pour la constitutive du prochain
parlement à strasbourg d'ici là on vous
souhaite de très bonnes fins de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
put